une production du studio sfr
[Musique]
bienvenue aux
questions parce qu'on vous invite à
chanter avec moins d'hommes plantes la
meilleure façon d'encourager s'en fait
le podcast c'est évidemment nous écouter
mais c'est aussi d'aller vous abonner à
notre page petrone sur la tâche mais qu
on vous avez tous les podcasts on tourne
au moment où est-ce qu'ils sont tournés
avant quelques heures plus tard pour
laisser le dan cole le faire sa magie
mais vous avez aussi accès à encore
moins de films qui est un segment
exclusif qu'on fait après les podcasts
on parle on jase domine mois avec nicole
parfois de la conversion bien d'avoir on
a profonde certains sujets certaine
réflexion puis ça s'est excusé pour mon
pétrole et rione fait qu'aller voir le
lien dans la description c'était même en
or c'est un job incarne l écoute ce que
j'avais pas vu depuis tellement
longtemps a fait depuis avant la
polémique était quelqu'un que que je
voyais souvent dans les événements dans
l'est dans les soirées vu qu'on était
match à miami là on s'est un peu perdu
de vue comme on a un peu perdu de vue
tout le monde la boulimie l'enterrement
un grand plaisir de renouer avec jay-z
de renouer avec est bien branche qui est
joli coup sûr un gars avec
angoisse mais un gars font un peu avec
d'autres gens ont dit qu'ils s'étonnent
jaser avec lui on a parlé beaucoup de
choses d'expérience et de choses en
commun mots puis on a fait la tournée
des petites grenouilles débarras tant
que musicien et on s'est souvent croisé
justement dans ces événements le fait
qu'on a sorti des vieux souvenirs
il y a dix ans et même plus qui nous a
parlé aussi de comment ça allait lui
dans cette ville depuis la pandémie ça a
été quand même beaucoup bouleversement
quant à 10 cette année ta vie en faisant
des choses en a tournée du québec tout
d'un coup ça arrête il faut se
renouveler c'est pas facile c'est pas
facile pour personne en fait c'est ainsi
qu' il a fallu se surpasser à jacques
passion doublé damas commence à la
weimar qui commence à laver qu'ils
émotions qui qui qui qui brassent encore
quand qui pensent ça c'est terrible
je pense que ça vous intéresse je pense
que
on est à peu près la même place que lee
dans nos vies s'effectua est également
tirée à pop de wes qu'on en est de
comment on a remis en question certaines
affaires liées à la pandémie toutefois
pas de conversation comme ceux plus
récents avec un peu moins d'agen de
s'équiper basé autour d'un sujet
particulièrement mais jusqu en freestyle
avec des amis fait que
on espère vous allez aimer la
conversation et à juste avant de vous y
laissez on va les remercier on commence
par
le podcast de cette semaine et présenté
par un faux bref un vrai et faux c'est
quoi ça honnêtement moi ben écoutez pour
parler mon expérience parce que
honnêtement c'est vraiment la bombe
c'est une infolettre en fait qui va sur
un court bref qui - comme tu t'inscris à
l'infolettre disent qu'ils font c'est
qu'ils te donne un résumé des nouvelles
de la journée ça prend maximum dix
minutes à l'est c'est super facile à
lire son téléphone super facile à lire
son ordinateur mois depuis que monsieur
escrime sont inscrits à l'infolettre du
matin et alain paulette du soir qui fait
le matin quand je me réveille gmi
nouvelle qu'est ce que je dois savoir
d'ajourner en gros points ça me prend
cinq minutes aller avec le chu j'ai
appris sur qu'est ce qui s'est passé la
veille ou qu'est ce qui s'est passé
d'important savoir et le soir je reçois
une autre info liette à 16 heures qui me
dis qu'est-ce que c'est passionnant
journée puis ceux dont ceux de ce que je
dois savoir en fait c'est bien être
c'est vraiment refuser en restant si je
suis moins actuelle en fait je veux plus
les réseaux sociaux complètement dit
souvent tu mets ton sur facebook tout ce
que tous les articles loin d être
informés mais d'avoir un genre de conte
à condenser matin même sort dans ton
petit café très précisément précisément
puis en plus de ce type parce que moi
aussi je consultais men ouverts à
travers leur fille de facebook mais ça
c'est polluer d'opinion pi2 de fake news
eux c'est des nouvelles légitime sans
opinion fonctionné que la nouvelle que
les faits pour vrai
le hip hop et swing ou comment dit on
m'a dit que le podcast là mais
honnêtement ça fait partie de ma routine
maintenant ça fait partie de ma vie puis
joueurs restés abonnés à l'infolettre
fait d'hommes je t'encourage toi le fond
vous encourage aussi vous qu écouter ce
que je dis est en ce moment en fait al
far à léo info bref point comme vous
n'avez qu'à écrire votre courriel dans
la liste de mailing ils vont vous en
voyez ça ils vont pas envoyé de
pollution non plus ne vous aurait pas de
plus vous aurez pas de pauvres est allé
voir ce un gros grève points comme c'est
vraiment la bombe let's go à bonn le
pacage aujourd'hui est présenté par
mindscape qui nous guide qui nous offre
une nouvelle collection de produits là
outre lui-même correction la dai tout ce
que vous avez besoin pour sentir bon
pour être propres pour être hydrater il
ya un baume à lèvres il ya un bon esprit
ce ces pauvres à titre le coach je
savais rien il ya un shampoing ironisant
il ya un bon match et il ya un déodorant
tout avec la même délicieuse odeur
d'indiquer vos appétits des séries toi
moi je cite les produits en nettement
c'est vraiment de la bombe le shampoing
revitalisant deux ans non on ne se cache
pas la taille que le body wash avec la
même petite odeur qui me colle si bien
la polio georges bach x men skate le des
océans du monde au tout quand je vais
courir dehors vous savez comme beaucoup
le baume à lèvres me protéger quand je
reviens pour hydrater ma peau
honnêtement ces produits là c'est
vraiment la bombe pis là on est à
quelques jours de la saint-valentin
c'est le cadeau idéal pour votre être
cher le ultra premium connection pour
sentir bon pour pour profiter du corps
de l'autre les hommes arrêtés parce que
ça devient petit peu trop caliente on a
un code promo pour vous qui le sans
filtre 20% de rabais avec la livraison
gratuite pour les ultra premium
collection ainsi que tous les autres
produits en skate aller voir ceux qui a
pimenté en spray votre saint valentin
fait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
arrête allez merci merci tellement marre
savoir pour vrai je suis vraiment
content les gars ont ceci entre
longueuil québec yang au québec qui est
né en 91 mais je travaille au oui oui
non c'est bien l'histoire québécois afin
que québec adopté une loi aussi bien
saint-elzéar de beauce est vrai bien
ouej et recherche
google i o oui mais voilà j'arrive à
québec je pense oui
mais c'est les années formatrices que tu
sens que moi ce qui me concerne c'est
moche neige continues puis j'ai démarré
à 10h parce que je n'ai pas passé
beaucoup de temps là pas mal moins que
toi mais tu me mets moi c'était mes
années d'université puis de cégeps mes
années formatrices ou est ce que c'est
de là que je viens c'est toujours ça
redevienne québec le très jeune est
estimé à 22 h et arrivée à 17 pour faire
une demi session au cégep
je suis reparti impression à l'âge et en
sciences humaines sans en maths et
jetaient pas motivé mon gars j'avais
l'impression d'être en 2d vers 6 puis
été mon rêve de puits secondaires 3,7
faire de la musique je fais comme lui je
suis en train de perdre mon temps au
mois d'octobre et je suis à fond dedans
je longe le cégep puis c'est là que j'ai
commencé à comme faire les efforts
nécessaires pour commencer à faire de la
musique mélange survenue après sa 22e
mais quand on s'est rencontrés tu t'en
souviens-tu la fois qu'on s'est
rencontrés est ce que ce taux ginger ah
oui à varna est vrai était venu ginger
way est devenu manager
ouais gérant le gars avec qui je
commençais à profit ni mes affaires mais
ouais je cherchais commun à ce moment là
on était comme un onglet une voix
féminine pour les tourner que je faisais
puis on l'avait pensé aliona parce que
bon là la blonde hugo avec qui je
travaillais à l'époque était prof de
chant pour lyon n'a qu' à un moment
donné mais à force de faire des tonnes
bon mais ça prendra un guitariste aussi
puis là-bas c'est là qu'on allait devoir
jouer mais c'est sûr vous étiez venu
mais moi je me souvenais d'une fois à
petite grenouille de sainte foy août où
tu joues et puis ça parfois j'avais vu
jouer et je fais entre ces deux iphone
tu jouer mais si tu avais pas mais ne
s'était pas encore fait à l'aller retour
d'abord non mais j'ai commencé les
petites grenouilles à 21 ans je faisais
encore les allers-retours jeu content
d'avoir fait les allers retours au début
parce qu'elle est petite grenouille
c'était discurso quand tu jouais au
moins là ça mais disciplinée a pas voir
pendant tout parce que bon j'avais pas
mon point 0 8 fois que je retourne en
beauce puis tout ça m'a quand même bien
discipline en partant mais why the past
s appuie ces drôles en sachant que je
venais ici j'ai repensé et pas mal la
même anecdote de cancon a commencé à
tirer nos étés tekton bande mouchetée
longchamp sony puis un flash que j'ai
fait mon erreur tout le corps ont depuis
trouvé ça dans le fond ce geste flash le
bal face à belfort j'imagine dans
l'effervescence du monde chaud
mais c'est sûr que c'est ce que tu as
fait ça j'ai trouvé ça le fun je
mangeais pas de sonner président est ce
que tu as fait a dit oui à bâle away
capot ou deux
la mine a en été avec moi en dehors des
classiques classique les chansons ni
savon l'aps est un langage de
chansonniers les caries c'est comme les
façonniers d'alphonse comme les
magiciens l'été ici pour partager des
trucs des chansonniers faut que tu
ailles dans des soirées sombre ou est-ce
qu'il ya juste des choses phoenix
partage le patin des quatre à six
banques à peau de chagrin
c'est vraiment les réseaux
gpon les cartels des chances et nile
beat party les places le
cdh rollmann parce que c'était moi qui
gérait la page remplacement chanceux ni
québec
et la glace à s'envoyer lire en place
mais petit mais annonce découle cd
bezannes et les titres renault et en y
est très formateur site web et
dans le fait qu'ils s'y sentent à temps
plein dans
2/3 demi guiglo tiers étaient des geeks
encaveurs bien aussi non puis
tranquillement vers le dans les
dernières années quelques geeks de
compos mais ouais c'est pas mal durant
200 240 geek par année
c'est la guide intacte dans le tank et
j'enlève les tigres nous il faisait
genre mercredi ou samedi oui à l'agent k
tu faisais catch où il y avait de cette
grenouille à quand j'ai arrêté d'en
faire aussi fait que je me remets un
homme aimant
georges seba je bouge pourrais pas dire
je sais pas honnêtement bouger comme
arrêter les petites grenouilles en 2018
et j'ai lancé mon album puis jetée comme
on reste assez je veux faire un switch
mais non quand j'ai arrêté on avait 17
ans encore fait que en faisant le tour
c'est pas long que ça tombe bien ça
c'est fou mais les petites grenouilles
man samara mais oui ça me ramène
tellement j'avais la main n'est pas
qu'une piasse les broc givré à une
piasse givre est des fois était chaud me
suis rendu deux heures et demie le monde
vos missions harbour partout même genre
je me rappelle que je me rappelle de
l'eau d'heure on dirait il rappelle
l'odeur des petites grenouilles je
l'aiderai dans les leurs c'était c'est
comme un mélange de bill produits
chimiques c'est quand même mais j'ai
tellement aimé se faire ça je n'ai pas
de temps et de ce fait longtemps que je
dirais que le jeune ait fait part en
cours d'année le bon type autant que toi
mais jean on la faisait en ben surtout
moins il y avait moins de bande de
croissance sur six mois c'est sûr nick
baynes mais je t'avais honte à la
jonquera italie à rimouski ou deux fois
puis québec et lévis
trois-rivières sûrement ici c'était
vraiment les débutants de cover stay
comme le conseille vraiment rue des bois
on est devenu commun c'est sûr quand le
juif c'était au début le ont joué
des 10 à 11 après une heure de break
deux ans et demi on jouait de
minuit à 1h
de deux à trois
contre trois heures de musique à moins
qu'ils entrent 10 le soir puis trois
heures du matin avec mon époque chez
avec deux heures de pause au travail qui
se fait pas pendant la pause c'est pas
vrai mais boire de l'eau peut tirer leur
n'en serait pas d'une sieste sur google
dit aussi ne pas tomber dans le westhoek
soumet la première fois qu'on allait à
jean piat d'un petit grenouilles les
loger leurs comptes et logis j'en ai
honte chez jo au deuxième dans l'espèce
de da par allart jean-pierre labat le
satirique puis pigeât ça c'est fois léon
l'échappée mais début vingtaine c'est le
meilleur moment pour vivre seul c'est
comme si cool dans un matelot pas l'avis
de l'agencé ni de la semaine d'avant pic
chez shopi jeu leurs deux ans est
capable de reset pas mal plus qu'un
timbre à cela ces deux jours moi j'ai
arrêté de boire mon durant pandémie
pendant mes coups j'ai mis trois
auberges comole je tenais j'avais la
bière social pas mal plus
c'est clair basque était si c'est trop
facile de juste finir défoncé mais oui
quand ça descend bien quand c'est le feu
sur tout mais c'est quand j'allais
devoir le team et ont joué le ça virait
un tabernacle
mutzig que j'allais voir mes temps de
musique live dans des morts de parts et
le beau joueur dépôt des salles de
spectacle mais déborde partie ce qu'un
petit et la dépasser une heure et demie
à j'ai complètement creux la cité l'
agent passe une heure et demie je
comprends que lance roquettes
les derniers le fameux dernier cette
embrouille et trois là ils se portent
des affaires mon gamin déjà
adopté on est comme tout le style je
m'envoie tout comme je peux pas croire
les autres entraînent quasiment se
battre comme on est en train de forer
pour lui qui est en train de vomir c'est
comme il se passer
je trouvais ça fascinant moi aussi puis
on dirait que j'étais pendant que je
jouais j'ai tellement vu du monde
mais tant que je savais en cours mais
que
non non pendant ces années là je voulais
tellement pas être encore plus vrai que
j'étais complètement désillusionnée de
ce que pouvait être une relation
amoureuse je veux rien savoir c'est sûr
je me fais faire ceux ci sont ken on
attend voir tabarouette
je me rappelle ces images est sorti
quand même deux ans et demi avec un
freak 13 ans dans des morts puis quand
j'allais mettons la chercher lorsque je
travaillais jusqu'à tort puis je restais
réveiller ou jeu gamer au début puis
j'ai acheté afin de son chiffre je me
rappelle rentrée agents dans un bar d'où
est-ce que y est trois heures puis le
monde me ramos leur manteau un coach est
classé le père à
leurs yeux ces candidats le salissent le
plus grand mystère même si quelques
ratés quand même niveau que tout le
monde n'a pas fait que tout le monde est
normal tout énormément normal mais
dictée pas dans le mode juste lauda
quatre
salles de soins que dans lequel louis et
puis je perds humides en même temps en
short à face quand tu es dedans c'est
comme tout est normal et couverts de jeu
les mouiller au complet mais c'est
normal
webkit et je sais ce que tu veux je sais
pas pourquoi c'est dans la mystique des
bars on dirait mais on parle de ses
souvenirs là c'est un autre vie
j'aimerais si je suis d'accord c'est
faux king un autre vie j'ai l'impression
que c'est steve ressentent ces phoques
et comment que ça a changé du jour au
lendemain c est ce que vous pensez que
c'est à cause de ces du temps décalé des
grosses années de ces bains de séguéla
dans psychologie c'est vraiment la
pandémie en direct on dirait que ça et
que ce concept leur mettons le 2 je peux
rentrer au bout dehors le samedi soir
puis que ce soit que ce soit tout le
monde ce comblement torche et 60 des
galas ce n'est du monde s'embrasse un
peu partout
c'est vrai que ça existe plus longtemps
cette classe cc c'est plus une option
c'est plus possible c'est l'ancien temps
va le monde voir une petite réserve pas
mal certain à partir de maintenant ouh
ouh ça bascule de l'autre bord piller là
c'est comme une fois qu'ils ont on ouvre
laval le monde qu'on pense x 4 parce que
c'est quand même dans nature humaine
nous instaurons chip chercher à faire le
party puis à connecter années qu'on se
resterait en ce moment quand l'élastique
vos larcher mais il va voter rocher on
veut s'ouvrir la base moi je pense que
laval va s'ouvrir à ceux qui ont comme
17 18 19 ans qui n'ont pas pu vivre sans
et encore je pense que basko j'imagine
que je recule maintenant de 10 12 ans
moi je pense que je verrai foule on
attend maintenant que les barreaux ce
domaine parce que j'ai tellement tripé à
faire ça aussi piger xiam est vraiment
sur ben oui là je sortais des fois dans
les bars mais la plus grande majorité du
temps que j'étais dans un bar c'était
pour jouer aussi fait qu il y avait
comme l'as fait de ses mots quand tu es
né l'appart élèves c'est sûr ça me coûte
rien d'alcool fait que je sais pas si
moi ma ma pensée biaisé par ça mais j'ai
comme l'impression que ceux ci ça ouvre
l'homme attend les bars
je serais pas surpris que ça vire fou je
pense que là mais juste le concept de
borda même j'ai l'impression que même
avant la pandémie ça ralentissait pour
un sens que ces bétons quelques unes aux
autres on avait 17 18 tables qui ont
commencé à sortir d'un bar on allait
dans des clubs on allait aux dames et un
pacte il y avait 2000 personnes c'est
pourquoi les hommes et filles allaient
pastèque oulmont allait le soir il faut
noter que j'ai
bien fait et pas une fois que je veux c
est l fort
mais bref ces concepts londres et comme
comment a commencé à mourir après ce
l'oeillade encore mettons les
psychologies un marché encore il ya
encore dix 10 lieu de rassemblement où
est-ce que tu étais paqueter mais j'ai
l'impression que
je passe les jeunes sont de moins je
pense aussi que les de l'internet le
gang gang sur le contact humain la
génération tu nous autres je pense que
plus ceux ci font quelque chose si on
faire quelque chose à social ça va être
bien chez nous jean cheese que de jouer
à leur bord je pense que ils ont compris
quelque chose que nous on n'est
peut-être pas compris à l'époque
pourquoi les tchèques des inconnus a
potent temps là capable d'entendre tes
amis jaser c'est pas tendre à fond
cette époque là c'était qu'il fallait
que tu sois au lean dans ta soir il
fallait pas genre tu pouvais pas être
être être admis demi-fond leçon sur
comment tu allais le parce que si
c'était de me tarde pas de fun mais si
tu étais en ligne dans ces affaires là
où est-ce que torcher avec des votes que
red bull mais tomba je me rappelle avoir
eu du fun l'arrivée des affaires qui
comme hier il t'arrive pas d'avis il y
at il
vraiment un temps sa petite faune tu le
ferais pas sinon tir du rapport
d'avancement en position de vivre de
quoi qu'on vivrait pas si ça examen
comme un peu d'allant et puis on ne sait
pas trop ce qui va arriver mais s'ils
jouent à tort culte exotiques
j'ai vu passer un un post sur instagram
c'est une fille qui était mimi vingtaine
qui faisait un genre d'appels ap appel à
tous mais un genre de genre de lettre
ouverte en dix ans
les deux dernières années j'ai
l'impression que tu es en train de
perdre un moment charnière de ma vie ou
est-ce que la côte la pandémie que je
pris chez nous - la pandémie bleus je
sais pas pour vous mais moi ça comme
tomber un moment où est ce que
ma vie comme rentrer un peu dans l'ordre
où est ce que je citais comme sa fille
tu es comme bien de ne pouvoir rester
chez nous peu plus casaniers un petit
peu plus de chez nous mais j'ai
l'impression que effectivement ça
m'était arrivé au début ma vingtaine
mettons d'autres fendues à kilos pendant
deux ans puis peut-être plus
on met en même temps social sur pas
aussi simplement que j'aurais vraiment
trouvé ça plus difficile qu'au moment où
est-ce que ça m'est arrivé aujourd'hui
dans ma vie pas pour vous autres moi
c'est un bon moment aussi mes
projets
mais c'est arrivé à un moment aussi que
je voulais justement être moins sa route
tout le temps tu méprises de chine ou
pis ça que ça comme ban a donné mais
je me sens en compte d'autres cas on
s'est parlé on s'est rappelé aux jo pipe
on sait quand on a réalisé qu'on s'était
pas vu depuis la pandémie
puis j'ai quand même réalisé dans le
fond j'ai vu pas grand monde ment pas
grand monde
ph ma blonde et quelques personnes ma
famille des fois mais genre si nous
autres on se croise et quand même
souvent c'est vrai on se croisait
souvent dandy dans des bords je demande
dans des soirées dans des shows on finit
vite apparaître comme genre de grosses
gagne deux mondes qui se connaissent
trop strict à barran composé de trois
semaines sans 3d metal mais non mais on
se croyait en dividendes et soit oric
finalement team et ont tout dit mais
tout se gagne mais tontine d'autres un
peu les gangs des musiciens québec et en
guinée et c'est tout le monde luttent
les prenez quelques mois pour acquis
j'utilise mettons tous ceux qui montrent
que je crois tout le talent qui se fait
par simon cette dame il élargit tiens je
te raconte que john à main
c'est se moquer quand même et j'ai
commis les deux minutes de quinon le jeu
ma vie sociale complètement changé le
monde que je voyais régulièrement
j'avais des relations qui étaient
peut-être pas pensé entretenir et crée
son corps existe plus c'est ce qui ce
qui est spécial je pense c'est que on le
sent on le sentait pas quand c'est
arrivé mais on s'en rend compte parce
qu'on en parle depuis
réfléchi comme créé c'est vrai tout les
gens que je voyais constamment j'y vois
juste plus de deux ans moi la paix - la
pandémie et ça et c'est arrivé dans un
moment qui m'a fait vraiment chier parce
que je voulais comme sortir un pays de
façon indépendante
c'était prévu pour février mars
puis c'est comme la première fois je me
lance et de l'assortir de quad
indépendants aussi fait juste un peu
clueless par rapport à qui je m'entoure
pas requis de quelle façon ça ça veut
dire quoi pousser quand même tu sais moi
c'est quand même compliqué lance là
dedans puis
je sais pas si à ce moment là je faisais
des petits grumeaux non plus je faisais
quelque chose de cover à l'atelier des
des super genre puis quelque chose qu'on
peut jeter comme okello 2020 c'est mon
année je sens mes trucs indépendant aude
et ça fait un an et on les gens ont
oublié
mais moi j'étais comme ok je me suis
grande un peu j'ai l'impression que
shiloh est ce qu'un jugement aurait put
gospi l'os est arrivé puis au départ
j'en voulais à je sais pas quoi mais
j'en voulais c'était un christ loin et
contre l'avis jeter comme moyen pour
quoi que j'ai fait puis mes jeux ça a
été charnière pour moi du fait que j a
fallu que je me mette à réfléchir
c'est seulement cherché non mais je me
souviens en mode qu'est ce que je dois
faire pour être heureux parce qu'en ce
moment clairement je suis malheureux je
suppose que je veux être pige pas ou est
ce que j'ai envisagé mon ali non plus
comment je peux me prêter malheureux au
moins
près pandémie ou post pandémie et il
était malheureux avant que ça tombe où
tu devines malheureux casse est tombée
je suis pense que je m'avoue est pas que
j'étais un peu malheureux pilote si
j'avais quand même très une vie que je
faisais du 4 5 6 chauds par semaine dès
fois je serai jamais chez nous je t'ai
jamais chez nous que j'ai constamment
entouré d'un connu souvent mais je t'ai
jamais chez nous puis là c'était comme
la première fois que je t'ai chez nous
dans mon qu'on doit québec à qu'est ce
que je fais depuis lors les premières
semaines c'est comme au quai le salon je
les méthodes dans le coin je mets mon
guide pour des micro puis j'essaie
d'écrire j'essaie de me changer d'idée
je me j'ai commencé à courir là aussi je
t'ai je faisais plein de truc que
j'avais jamais pris le temps de faire
parce que je t'ai complètement perdu
puis cette pause là mais vraiment amener
à réfléchir à pourquoi je suis pas bien
pourquoi je % pas ma place puis simon
hix peter pis je vais partir à prendre
de trop virtuel des fois tu réfléchis
pas que de la musique pilote s'en va
loin dans ta tête des fois un peu trop
mais des fois bonne place aussi puis je
me suis rendu compte qu raymond j'ai
commencé la musique pour écrire de la
musique heavy metal group ltée je me
rendais compte aussi j'étais tout le
temps à non je veux pas de blancs trop
compliqué je me fais tout le temps
niaiser et puis je dénonce le patron là
un inconscient mais là je commence à
être conscients puis la pandémie comme
et comme arrivé avec ok ils logent à
faire des trucs pour me faire plaisir
faut que je fasse du sport faut que je
commence à écrire d'eton puis je vais
arrêter de mettre des meilleurs a
rencontré quelqu'un tient puis en mai
tel qui d ailleurs qui tout est traité m
j'ai rencontré je dirais à faire de la
musique je rencontre beaucoup de gens
fument beaucoup de gens intéressants
aussi autant 0 intéressant autant qui en
a qui sont intéressants puis il ya bien
du monde intéressant que je t'ai comme
nos facs d'attentes 07 août à l'aller
par super intéressant parce que ça va
être intéressant pour toi tu est
inconsciemment un seul beau jeu c'est
faux mais j'ai comme l'impression qu'à
citer pendant ses deux boucles à jeter
comme je l'avais pas tendre et ça a
côtoyé je pense en tout cas avec du
recul on
[Rires]
se met encore une fois en 10 ans 11
voiliers ont été amis ou un métier je
t'ai pas tant confidences ce n'était pas
mon confident lançant ce qu'ils étaient
on se connaissait pas
quand j'avais pas de confident non plus
bas cenon métier moi car je voyais
c'était au lit le
qui fait tiquer keith mathlouthi les
remercie mais ouais bah oui mais on
dirait que c'était cool les bords mais
on dirait que j'ai comme alimenter une
look d'éternel validation de vouloir
plaire à qui je vais apprendre tel
tourner parce que c'était groupe d'âge
la a probablement vécu son école
secondaire en tête anita l'année qui
s'est écoulée hitler plus j'apprenais
florent individuelle d été puis c'est
cool j j va arriver là dessus aussi
mince pour ça que j'ai couché une chose
pour ce qui me fait triper effectué
jeter comme panier dans cette espèce de
l'eau plate constamment à être à la
recherche de validation qui est à 10,0
moi même puis je pense qu'avec les
années ça c'est comme accumulé accumulé
accumulé puis ça comme tout relâcher
quand la pandémie tarifs des comme dans
la
forme et
j'ai commencé à jouer ce qu'est il faut
faire des trucs qui me plaisent moi pis
tant mieux si ça plaît aux autres plutôt
que qu'est ce qui plairait aux gens
c'est une question piège c'est un toit
une réflexion pierre dans ce sens que
tu t'attends penser qu'ici c'était le
type de tourner si je fais ça comme ceux
le monde ils vont presser mais ses
ouvres d'art
si tout se trouve ça bon t'es sûrement
postule au pis si tu essaies de
changer un peu la manade qui te fait
instinctivement les choses pendant les
un peu plus au final si putois puissent
eux aussi les jeunes voileux gens le
ressentent
puis ça sexy - en aide à discuter je
pense que
ccc jamais une bonne idée de notre eau
est question mais les gens leur centre
l'authenticité aussi l'homme et oui
vraiment les gens sont pas dupes ça
passait sous scellés longtemps je disais
quand tu es convaincu et convaincant
mais je me rends compte plus sa box
pauvreté c'est pas parce qu'ils étaient
certaines quelque chose que c'est vrai
mais tu peux être convaincant pour les
autres personnes qui regardent mais il
ya une personne qui ne réussira jamais à
convaincre sétois exactement aller au
fond de l'eau fondue truc loti basket du
monde qui font un don qui crée quelque
chose dans l'optique de plaire aux gens
des fous aucun heurt plein dans le monde
qui sont des superstars internationales
qui qui va être même pas sur leurs
propres affaires
sauf que je regrette de vivre avec ça
quand même ça c'est vraiment la partie
la plus toxique et y mettons petit créé
quelque chose que tu es vraiment fier il
peut se passer douze affaires soumettons
le monde embarque dans son projet puis
ils m'ont même si oui où ça fait pas
vraiment vagues puissantes ça reste pas
mal le site est vraiment fier de ce que
tu as fait il te reste au moins 113
l'affecté fiable que tu as fait même si
la lèche bottes et comme existent pour
toujours mais pitois tmp tout est fier
d'avoir créé ce site et si ça marche
papier en plus des paupières l'été tony
trier ça c'est
parce que même si ça se peut que ça lève
toi même si tu essaies de faire des
couilles dans l'optique que ça lève le
dit - mais au moins comme tu dis si tu
le fils est peut-être en est avec toi
même en le faisant au moins 6 à l'efs
pas bête sera pas à ça à paul vettier en
plus j'aime pas ça si c'est moi j'ai
fait des couilles et paul fort et en
plus exact mais mais c'est que c'est ça
si je t'ai connu dit je t'ai campagne
dans le loop puis après c'était mon
premier album était très années 60 à la
française puis j'ai adoré faire ça j'ai
j'ai énormément écouté jean c'est grand
charles aznavour brel gainsbourg
puis je suis embarqué dans cette
personne là parce que j'avais envie de
le faire puis je trie pas le faire puis
on dirait que l'accumulation de tout ça
c'était tout le temps crime je suis
jamais - même si
c'est ce qui est au tce avec faire de la
musique de l'art en général mais en ce
que je dis je c'est du moins ce qui est
le chef et avec faire de la musique
c'est que si tu connais pas avec ce que
tu fais de plateformes non et c'est ça
c'est là que ça devient l'autre c'est là
que ça devient jobs alors que je pense
pas qu attend factice de portes phone
à moins d'être vraiment mon acteur
sa part à tout un effet domino à ceux
qui comme moi qu'ils font bien vu tant
mieux s'ils sont heureux
mais ce que moi ce qui me concerne ça me
rejoint payet qui font moi c'est ça mais
il y en a aussi qui font de la musique
et le trop commercial mais vraiment
bourgeois il venu ici mais jean guy
triple saut à skis de source qui fait la
rti genre
ça passe à radio puis parfait pigeon lui
parfaitement son x ma voix de celui je
la connais pas mais j'ai ici un peu ce
qui dégage en moins qu'il y ait au moins
il ya la connexion d'authenticité quand
il fait quelque chose d'important fait
que ce fait pour se recentrer sur toi
autre que le sport puis la musique
j'ai rouvrir désolé amoureux ben j'ai
arrêté de me faire croire qu'ils jettent
et
qui je pensais que j'étais puis j'ai
juste essayé d'y aller avec je sais pas
j'ai commencer à m'écouter j'ai commencé
à baisser mais garde un peu sur plein de
trucs j'essaie de m'ouvrir beaucoup
j'essaie de m'intéresser à plein de
trucs je sais pas ça a été
c'est en 2018 2019 ça a été des années
quand même rohff mentalement pour moi
puis j'avais l'impression ok j'ai bouclé
la boucle je suis guéri tout ça mais je
pense j'ai mis le plastron un petit peu
trop vite ça appelé puis
je sais pas ça comme le parnasse de
pause l'appui bon l'année qui en a suivi
j'ai l'impression d'avoir un peu
vieilli bovier de façon péjorative mais
comme pris conscience de plein de trucs
l'expérience da sagesse un petit peu
j'ose croire
j'ai des cheveux blancs peu fait que je
veux ça doit vouloir dire senti peu mais
ce que j'ai fait de juger ça rate in me
poser des questions que j'ai fait les
choses selon mon instinct puis j'ai
arrêté d'être compressé
que les choses se passent ma blonde me
l'a appris beaucoup ça de récup rice
personnes attend près toi qui prends ton
temps fait bien les choses puis c'est
pas mal à ça que ça m'a servi
cette pause la
décence et ailleurs c'est vraiment un
point capital mocistes un travail
constat que je fais j'ai commencé à en
forme de y en avait quand même mais une
fois que tu
trouves plus des ports aux expériences
pillot alao différents points de vue -
même si tes opinions changent pas sur x
ou y sujet au moins d'avoir été capable
de
d'emmagasiner d'autres visions du monde
ça rendement ça m'a vraiment rendu plus
zen sanogo rendait vraiment comme de jeu
se laisser tomber les
l'espèce de
présuppositions que j'avais des choses
je suppose présuppositions le mot que
cherche le mais ça m'a permis de laisser
tomber les l'espèce de
je sais pas c'est quoi le bouquet
cherche quand tu arrives avec
les victimes et préjugés des préjugés
mais quitte à s'y intéresser confirmer
ce que tu pensais déjà au moins de
donner la chance d'obtenir jeudi des
examens exact puis ça ça on dirait que
ça m'a amené un niveau de 2 p lus grande
attente - mais c'est un travail constant
puis sapphire vient de lâcher les cordes
tête blanche et prix ils ont un peu
c'est comme ma foi c'est lourd d'être
constamment
en combat même si on est plus ou moins
consciente quelque chose - tout en train
de jeu martin penser de même où je pense
de même puis je me laisse pas penser le
masque système loupe qui peut quand même
c'est des fois ça peut porter fruit mais
je pense plus souvent qu'autrement ça
peut nuire puis plus souvent qu'on pense
la décision de tenir les rênes nous
appartient ou implicites à nous de
l'arche est sûre ça s'applique pour en
plein de choses le pied dernièrement
donne juste le m puisque tout à fait
avec dont celle d'adam lever les
notifications le journal exemple banal
sus bourse aux gens
d'enlever les notifications qui popent
constamment ce ton si de temps en temps
passes tu le fais encore mais chez que
tu dis que tu l'avais tu l'avais fait du
moins en vacances
de faire sucer aussi de reprendre le
contrôle sur ta propre narrative sur ma
propre ville
depuis ce pouvoir là on l'a mais c'est
souvent maintenant moins d'un mois ces
jours ci sur tout et puis je dois depuis
depuis après aude évidemment
c'est les médias sociaux c'est que tout
le tasp hergé des immeubles depuis que
concertée des business puis tout le
temps d y mettre tant à faire tout le
temps des messages tout le temps dit
au final j'ai l'impression perdre le
contrôle constamment mais quand on se
rappelle que c'est toi qui donne
contrôler sa toile et les chalets betis
tatouage les sels de fer qui renonce à
sa doxa dois pas me diriger c'est le
même principe avec des opinions souvent
le tout tient tellement mordicus à ton
point que tu es prêt à pourrir de
l'intérieur
pour essayer de défendre ton point même
si ce n'est pas un argument est clair
avec quelqu'un d'autre de défendre ton
point dans ta tête mais de laisser aller
le fait qu'une autre personne pense pas
comme toi oui sûr aussi c'est assad
appartient puis c'est le même principe
chaque fois que tu vois n'importe quelle
information que des gars aussi quand tu
secours dont phil woodward ça tu
appartiens pas te laisser forcer par se
laisser atteindre par ce président
georges frêche comme si je l'avais
accompli le clip mais c'est sûr mais
t'en parle même pas ce que c'est un
constat qui n'ont jamais qui c'est c'est
moi qui ai le contrôle c'est moi qu'elle
contrôle de caisse qui me dérange moins
fait au final
c'est rare qu'on est dans une situation
de vie ou de mort
à n'importe quoi ce n'est pas soit un
pub du nord non ça dans le contrôle de
ces bosses il faut city c'est beaucoup
mais on a toujours le contrôle là dessus
mais pour revenir à ce que tu dis par
rapport aux opinions pu ne pas vouloir
d'un world j'ai entendu avec exane est
quelqu'un dire
il discutait avec un autre personne
justement qui était très fermé puis lui
jodie l'autre mais coûtent plus tu
m'écoutes pour me répondre mais coûte
même pas que ma comprendre une mise à
sac en fait ça a commencé à signer un
match comme c'est vrai des fois que tu
commences une discussion sur un sujet tu
écoute parler l'autre mais pas tant que
ça parce que je sais en train de penser
à ce que tu vas répondre puis ça c'est
juste un premier réflexe de fermeture
tant qu'à moi de te demander ton idée a
peu à être faites mais restent ouverts
quand même très puis ça aussi c'est
drôle cette enquête en par ben rôle
mais je reçois fanga titulaire parce que
moi aussi je serai peut-être un honneur
que je cache de pas parce que moi je
pense de même que sin même qu'il faut
compléter et et vice versa pas parce que
quelqu'un va penser de même qu' au
raison qui a tort puis même si c'est
maintenant qu'on comprend l'exemple
aussi précis du vaccin est en ce moment
même si l'auto la dame on est des cons
véhicule c'est que c'est la bonne chose
à former le gouvernement
quel gouvernement avec les maires dit
merci au gouvernement
vt on est convaincu puis honnêtement je
peux être fondamentalement à être
certain que c'est la chose que c'est la
bonne solution
mais rendue où est-ce qu'on a amené dans
la pandémie mac processus
je vois pas faire changer l'opinion
personnes en mode sina où un temps fort
chez que cette personne mais selon m
union jean radio est ce qu'on en ait
deux ans in mais perd personne à qui tu
va en parler vos changer d'idée sur tout
poste si tu le fait d'une manière
agressive agressif confrontation c'est
hier soir le yart et ici avec quelqu'un
que tu connais qui peuvent expliquer
vocalement comptes-tu puis contre le
gouvernement petit
au final sur péno aspect c'est un être
humain qui est qu'il ya plein de belles
qualités pic adeline sûrement pas si
c'est toujours sans baisser on a discuté
on ne peut discuter longtemps parce que
je n'aime pas mais tj ch comme dans le
respect du tout à ce que tu penses puis
pourquoi ce pittis à l'attaqué l'autre
puisque juste être peut-être serving
rien
mais ça ça démarre tient plus à
marseille fabrice c'est comme ça mais
faut jamais que ça soit sur le temps de
vouloir convaincre non plus c'est la
clause ferme pour mincir en 6 a tout le
temps été tout de suite parlé d'attitude
elles baissent et de poser des questions
poser des questions aux connaissances
demande des fois si votre téléphone la
personne vous comme se rendre compte
qu'elle n'a pas de réponses à ces
questions
pas trop orgueilleux
bouquin loubat dans son train penser
comme mais oui mais oui si ceux ci mais
plus largement que le vaccin ne suis pas
convaincu ta propre idée l'opinion des
autres mais
ça leur appartient et puis ça appartient
à toi de
le
comment tu le laisses mille comment tu
l'as 6000 puis comment tu reprendre puis
le laisser aller puis de laisser-aller
l'opinion des autres même si les allées
l'opinion des autres une chose mais j'ai
fait les l'opinion des autres sur toi
ces erreurs mais non mais non mais si
ces exercices assez lointain j'avais une
conversation dernièrement
au téléphone puis je me disais
l'opinion que les gens ont de moi que
les gens qui ne me connaissent pas on de
moine ça devrait rien faire c'est clair
ça devrait rien me faire mais c'est pas
seul puits mais je sais c'est pas ce qui
se passe dans ville - sauf que
si tu es capable de le rationaliser sa
devrait rien de faire l'écho des spots
of rationaliser ce qu'avait laissé
s'étoffe main sur tout cas qu'on est
comme tu l'as été aussi exposés au
public le jeudi à od maintenant le monde
ils sont fait des idées de moins ils
sont fait des idées de toi c'est du
monde qui nous connaissent pas qui des
matrices de nous des idées qui sont des
fois oui à kruth mais des fois que tu es
comme mais c'est tellement passe au pied
je savais pas ce soir est ou pas que ce
soit ça devrait
patrizio n'est ce pas moins affectés par
l opinion des gages à l'opinion positive
dans l'autre ils ont le droit d'avoir
leur opinion le toit tout le monde a le
droit d'avoir son opinion dont x ou y à
fond mais des gens qui te connaissent
pas leurs opinions ça donnerait rien ou
face à du beau les réseaux sociaux mais
ça à du lait puis ça ça fait partie du
lait 1 de données c'est je vois les
réseaux sociaux maintenant le messenger
le dit un mot banon des postes facebook
je vois ça comme un micro et un grand
pas une personne dans une grande forme
cette personne là à vous dire quelque
chose dans ma main le micro sous le
donne à quelqu'un qui a de quoi à dire
pis mais bien souvent ceux qui parlent
le plus fort sur les réseaux sociaux de
façon différente or c'est pour les gens
à qui on donnerait un micro dans une
assemblée en tout cas souvent dit ici
c'est ça que je trouve bah si je trouve
ces sols et des réseaux sociaux c'est
que les gens quittent adore petit
respecte qui vont donner plein d'amour
ils vont le faire en personne n'a
justement on n'a pas peur du temps ceux
qui le détestent dont le faire un
message avec c'est sûr que c'est sûr que
quand tu es dans te parlais de l'espèce
de mer des réseaux sociaux que c'est
facile tomber dans le look pas se rendre
compte que t'as pas le cateau le
contrôle au final c'est quand même
c'est quand même fait of de dissocier ça
oui parce que tu vois juste souvent line
et les commentaires négatifs les gens
qui râlent mais attend de tahoua
négatif et bien plus vocal et bruyant
que le positif c'est ce qui c'est qui
fait qu'aider fois l'atmosphère
sur les réseaux sociaux pas encore une
fois là on est on est toutes ont choisi
qui compte qu'est ce qu'on s'en suit il
souffre a vraiment aimé la jeunesse pour
ceux qui les manient c'est comme
ça fait quinze minutes que je regardais
s'accrochant denjean pour croquer en
normandie c'est comme qu'est ce qui se
passe les y ait quelque chose de la
caisse qui viennent créé ce
fait avait vu l'homme fort l'eau facile
par la caf en déminage est clean et mon
jeu - je pense que je suis cent trente
personnes maintenant que c'est juste des
gens que je connais personnellement
week-end à bord genre national
geographic qui est notre fils les
médecins olivier en octobre 2010 mais
pour vrai que j'ai fait jacqueline et
mon jeu absolument parce que je suis
rendu j'ai fait ça aussi 0 puis après ça
me réabonner ça fait du bien parce que
ça faisait ça je regardais réseaux
sociaux puis petit comparé au tome est
ce qui importe c'est qui suit wallon
doit par exemple si tu compare avec la
meilleure version des gens parce que la
personne qui va mettre les oeufs à la
barre comme il y en a qui vont mettre ça
de même de façon théâtrale eux alors
pays on le tient moins tu te compare
avec les succès de piste ovale et
succèdent des gens qui sont zéro comme
toi ouais c'est maintenant qu'ils ont
aucunement les mêmes aspirations du mans
le mans - nancy clairement c'est mettant
quelqu'un qui est je sais pas qui est
super c'est que ce soit en danse je
danse pas bien mais pourquoi j'ai pas
dit ça
c'est pas juste content pour cette
personne l'a même comparé à dire crise
moi je prends en train de faire des
shows c'est un exercice la fin
d'affaires de d'arrêter de voir tout
comme la compétition puis debout juste
te mettre des lunettes de has been cool
pour lui c'est ce maillot ça arrive à
semer un crime a fait ça c'est cool tu
ça fait du bien d'être heureux pour le
monde non
si au final c'est
souvent la réalité il peut être crise
moins de bruit parce qu'on voit pile à
une personne peut être crissement ce que
ce faux mais j'en ai plein d'aspects de
sa vie qui qui qui quitte moi ce qui
chiffonne c'est fake
puis c'est pas vrai que récemment le
succès qui t'aurait ou que tu voudrais
vous faire en sorte que tu aurais pu
l'être bolland dans les listings c'est
ce paquet
c'est super ça se mesure pas au trident
au final s'est trouvé qu est ce que toi
fonctionne pour toi pour georges eu
cette balle et puis si c'est prouvé elle
joue aussi le spa même chose pour tout
le monde sait les réseaux sociaux c'est
un peu comme quand on rencontre
quelqu'un qu'on parle cinq minutes au
barça of corse qui va montrer sur son
beau jour la piraterie il faut pas dire
ouais mais c'est ainsi c'est difficile
je suivais mes pièces oui c'est ça si
c'est la même chose mais sur les réseaux
sociaux tels que par l'aspect vocal puis
contact humain puis un temps le luxe de
dfa si ce que tu veux dire le réécrire
ce que topo en personne non plus fixé
ici c'est assez facile dans un sens de
citer dit que tout va bien les ihu stop
même si je peux tout va bien tout moment
et une caméra d'en face c'était filmé
jamais toi même si tu es toi-même même
si je dois montrer le moins beau pays
plus beau moment que tes films et un
camarade en face tu es jamais 100%
complètement toi-même factieux tout le
temps une part du tout à qui l'on
choisit de montrer dans le pot beau il
est ce que tu choisi de montrer que je
peux montrer c'est comme ça se fait
qu'ils travaillent femme rencontrée elle
lira parent d'un des amis façade de
politesse
c'est rare qu'on va être 100% soit moi
je m'en fou ce que les gens pensent je
verrai si rare qu'on semaine à cette
heure il a
géré poser une grande question reste
posée avant de poser question qui est
peut-être temps de parler parce que
c'est à paris tata parle pas mais
mettant quatre pense à augusta - c'est
quoi les émotions qui qui surgissent
mettant
qui surgissent ckoi llc poste
j'ai longtemps fait l'exercice d'essayer
de voir du positif parce que ça serait
me mettre la tête dans l'eau de me dire
qu'il y en a pas du tout positif le
c'est sûr qu'ils réfléchissent en trouve
mais
le premier sentiment qui me est pas mal
de l'amertume chez des gens moins c'est
que je disais tantôt que jeter dans une
loupe de validation
c'est ça faisait comme cela si sept ans
que je faisais des barques par tout ce
que j'allais c'est comme tu es beau tu
es bon c'est été autant assez cool ce
que tu fais bab l'appui veut pas de bien
beaux sites précités grande et d'avoir
les pieds sur terre c'est flatteur mais
une petite embarquer là dedans petit
puisse commencer à comprendre aussi
coiffage pour te faire dire des boutons
à ses patins de loeb c'est sûr pitié et
au dg on l'écouté parce que tu es tu es
dedans ben ali puis je dire là le tapis
rouge on s'était fait un intérêt de chez
chery beaulieu qui en serait autrement
c'est là pour regarder le terrain en
exemple oui c'est moi je n'avais jamais
vraiment écouté aux démêlés rejeté comme
je connais pea je vais l'écouter puis
beaucoup en plus d'intérêt si ça ne
l'était qu'on a commencé à se voir c'est
beaucoup vu condensé des parties fait
que jeter comme je vais regarder ça
c'est sûr tous est venu qui ont géré
cette jeunesse là j'ai eu envie de le
faire
quand j'ai vu c'est comme la première
fois que tu avais des beaucoup d'abonnés
senti la grande quand je sortais puis tu
étais sorti en décembre 2010 est mon
premier album c'est en février 18
j'étais curieux dans les bars à ce
moment la vie dans ma tête le 1 + 1
c'était juste si je fais haut des seins
ça va être cool pas joué encore avant
mon psy je me dis que je dise
aujourd'hui le procès parce que je me
disais à l'époque lé avec du recul je me
rends compte que c'était ça mais je suis
retombé dans ma loupe de validation je
me fais rire je suis bon pitch boxe à me
faire du bien en plus je vais apporter
du spotlight à l'album que je viens de
sortir je vais sortir de là fini les
chaudes cover
rouler là tu vas est une star mais au
moins quand je vais faire des choses ça
va être pour mille tonnes c'est le
pourquoi j'ai commencé à vouloir faire
de la musique c'était pour finalement me
rendre là fait que j'ai juste vu un
faucheur 4 pour mirande puis
je suis juste tombé là-dedans je t'ai
comores si je fais ça ça va me flatter
l'égo ça va faire du bien puis
maintenant au avec du recul c'est
beaucoup d'amertume parce qu'ailleurs
c'est la chose qui m'a le plus choqué
dans ma tête de ma vie
tu
jusqu'à celle des pages pour attendre
longtemps souvent puis il tire pas les
mêmes repères que tu peux avoir
quand tu vis des choses qui étaient pas
se poser vivent plus fait que tu es un
peu confronté aux pires de toi même mais
en tout cas moi la façon j'ai vécu c'est
que je leur aval est tout le temps que
je l'aïe andrade en garder quelqu'un
d'un prospectus puis qui sauvent pas
facilement tout droit d'une table mais
exact puis il ya quand même beaucoup de
bobos qui n'étaient pas réglées en
dedans moi qui les plaies en jeu
seraient ouvertes php capable un moment
pour que ça ouvre devant tout le monde
le jeu met dénature un petit peu parce
que là je t'ai comme ans qu'est ce qui
me ferait du bien oui c'est vrai qu'en
choisir des bars et la validation cet
élégant
puis à la fin je t'ai je me sentais plus
moi-même du tout je me sentais
complètement vide à mon retour ça a été
plusieurs mois quand même des thérapies
juste parce que juste et plus capable de
jouer là dedans je voulais jouer
l'impression de noailles et puis je
voulais vraiment à sortir puis avec du
recul
1 ça mais c'est un mal nécessaire dans
le sens parce que blanche
safa lui ça pour que je réalise certains
trucs que je réprouve peut-être réaliser
autrement mais le ça a été ça mais c'est
beaucoup d'amertume parce que mon lit
l'espoir que j'invite perçoit pour ma
musique originale finalement ça fait
complètement l'effet inverse parce que
ça en sortant l'album à février c'était
pour commencer à faire peut-être des
salles à l'automne puis le monde de la
musique les diffuseurs sait un peu plus
ce champ gauche qui champ droit mettant
au défi bien souvent c'était difficile
mais bouquet des chaux pop parce que
s'ils pensent que j'ose croire que
propose le matériel est pas moins mais
bien souvent c'est ce que mon bouquin me
disait à l'époque si je pense pas qu'ils
aient coûté mais tout ce que je fais
mais delgado de ses produits testés
daudet avant d'être le musicien plutôt
que
discréditer un peu l'artiste puis je
peux le comprendre d'un point de vue
externe maintenant si c'est ça je me
suis j'espère avoir mon propre jeu avec
rat c'est fini je fais au des joueurs
les goûts complètement flotter
maintenant je sais c'est fini
dans le vert maintenant je vais juste
mes compos mais j'avais j'étais
complètement lâchant de pansements un
piti sait aussi que pour quelqu'un pour
qui
l'image puis par est important pareil
jeudi discuter de ce que tu me dis plus
de ce que tu fais avec les bols tout
d'un coup sûr mais ce tout métonymie
animale et humaine que c'est plutôt moi
qui décide qu'est ce tu projettes le spi
toi qui qui qui arrive sur cinq qui met
ça face des élections concernant non
classés comme c'est aux autres qui les
gens ont des jeunes des toits a dit on
pas vu qu'ils te connaissent pas encore
vu mais je ne veux pas la prod ou des
acides
l'image est un spectacle lourde menace à
ce qu'est
vraiment of de dire
plus car ce cas sa force tient pas
compte parce que tu sais je sais après m
je remets tout le mond paraître
n'aurions tout ce que l'image que je
projette dans les médias car audi fait
ce qu'il veut avec ce tacle et si des
sites qui produisent quelque chose se
passe ce projet mais je sais pas si
j'étais si conscient de ce à ce moment
là mais ces sommes si j'allais dire
c'est parce que mettons mon année puis
votre année la subséquente
j'ai l'impression qu'on n'était pas à
100% conscient des règles du jeu les
métiers les plagistes pas des règles du
jeu papa du jeu daudet le même mois
largement maintenant je pense que le
mettons mettons site inscrire dès
maintenant sonacos stable à 6 dans le
show et tu le sais que tu sais que le
montage va être phonique des musiques
drôle c'est moi je note que je parle
pour moi je m'en allais la boj avait
aucune idée oui c'est vrai qu'est ce qui
allait être montré je pouvais même pas
savoir quelle est la lettre la direction
du montage sa lettre est dramatique
comme avec l imagine que jesse à
l'épaule imessage dramatique comme avec
sébastien benoit elle est du genre est
avait aucune idée j'avais pour une idée
de ses pilotes lance le pis tu sais pas
qu'est ce qui va se passer de ses passes
avec croit le ton tu sais pas aucune
dette et tandis que là je pense que
c'est inscrit aujourd'hui tu vois là
pour donner un show puis s'était pas
trop risqué si ces montages et fournir
envers tout en maintenant est-ce que tu
coules avec moi il faut capter vu de
près mais ce bon
c'est pas j'ai pas aimé ça mais plus
souvent qu'autrement il est des
situations qui sont montrés que ce pas
arriver comme ça parce que
tolère d'un épais à cause de ça ça c'est
plus fruste y plus frustrant qu'autre
chose parce qu'elles ne tombent dans la
justification puis au final les gens pub
ont pas envie de temps à justifier ils
ont vainement un bilan exceptionnel
c'est fini l'interprète comme ils l'ont
vu les psys fini après ça mathieu
gibaud que j'ai patrie pays c'est que
je sais pas quand je l'a rendu à
regarder les épisodes
de 13 ans que ce que tu as vu
c'était patois ou que oust et une partie
toi qui tu es l'homme et tous les
pouvoirs ou this book union au baiia des
parties de moi qui ont démontré que
c'est un mois et des partis moi qui ont
montré que je voulais pas m'avouer que
je t'ai demandé le logement raconte
aujourd'hui c'est vrai j'avais
je t'ai patins
j'avais beaucoup de manque de confiance
en moi je pense quand j'ai fait puisque
moi et on te connais ça avant ouais
j'aurais jamais dit j'aurais jamais dit
alix serait vraiment pas confiance en ce
groupe et je me dis aujourd'hui mais
dans ce sens que j quinquin l'ogive
quand je t'ai vu j'ai tapé dans une
folie folie que je connais moi c'est mes
parents que c'est lourd mais que tout le
monde se pose c'est où que j'avais
jamais la situation qui fait ressortir
ce nom mais jamais je vivais ce genre de
situations chaudes en basse caste genre
de situation lorsque pointe le point
noir du nez et je pue le jeu man vs que
je fuis situation le hockey
non j'avais juin je pense que je pense
pas je pense je manquais beaucoup de
confiance en moi c'était totalement dans
la façade puis
comme je disais tantôt c'était tout le
temps là dans la validation que je me
faisais croire que je me faisais
confiance petit sopi
pigeon
non666 nice
la validation quand même parce que parce
que quand cette confirmation à cette
validation le qui vient de l'externe
comme tu dis tu peut l'interpréter comme
la confiance mais c'est pas la confiance
et une confiance qui fabriqué par par
les commentaires des autres le tu penses
tu es quelqu'un de super confiant
jusqu'à tant qu'arme et a pu se - fiq
lot des as qui n'ont finalement je doute
classement - george est un syndrome de
l'imposteur ou à 9 heures puis
l'allemand ni personne me dit que c'est
autre personne me dit que c'est bon puis
qu'est ce que je tente rien à faire mais
c'est c'est sûr que ça allait mener
açores
quand j'y pense parce qu'un type une
idée de ce que tu vis en lviv 1-1 après
super fun deuxième à vis de ce que tu
vis en le voyant qu'habré soit c'est en
fini troisième avec ce que les gens ont
perçu qui ont vu de ce qui est à faire
taxer de jongle avec 3 perception de
toi-même puis ça c'est marrant parce que
c'est là que tu dis chiche quoi je suis
qu est ce qu est ce qui est vrai qu est
ce qu il faut c si la confiance en soi à
cet effet qu'un petit met à douter tout
ce temps puis comme tu disais c'est en
tout cas moi afin de s'acheter tellement
vide j'ai tellement vidé le genre drainé
complètement que j'ai même plus la force
de savoir qui j'étais réellement affecté
juste complètement vide de même plus la
force de se battre pour conserver la
personne que tu étais juste comme acquis
deux mois qu'est ce qui se passe je
quitte mon coiffeur puis je le faire
moyer au final ça c'est long à
reconstruire le passé ça a été plusieurs
mois mais aussi de thé ce que tu fais
tes parce que tu es temps exact fait
juste faire puis sainement est purement
d'année battles interviennent en face
des comores au temple mais tout ça
c'était loin d'être brandie
été extrêmement
d'accepter de gauche à droite de ce
genre
c'est la vie que c'était pas ça le
projet le puck man pilote puis une fois
que tu es dans tt pas embarquer
là-dedans ben t'es tu es loin pour
revenir faire
pour venir trop bien de faire de beaux
labo est toujours là
mais non c'est super mais non ça a été
long l'un d'eux comme de juste
laisser aller par le courant peut amener
de paniers une roche table naksa sens
bruce rivière
l'amertume toi aussi finalement à
l'amertume je sais pas parce qu'il ya
plein d'affaires que je réponse
je regarde pas les on ferait pas il se
serait passé entre deux familles je ne
regrette pas les connexions je ne jette
pas les personnes que j'ai rencontrées
je regrette pas un saint mais aussi je
regrette pas ce que ça m'a amené là très
bien que ça m'a porté des années après
les gens qui me suivent maintenant ils
suivre pour les raisons que j'aime qui
me suivent même suivre parce que je
montrais l'activité physique pitié des
affaires qui m'intéresse il suffit pour
le patinage c'est exact exact fait que
maintenant j'en suis reconnaissant mais
je suis aussi conscient
que si j'avais jamais fait ça si
c'est exact mais c'est ça parce que je
suis conscient pis j'ai assez confiance
en moi que je sais que j'ai pas fait ça
j'aurais fait autre chose que j'aurais
été heureux oscille tim george aurait
fait autre chose de ma vie parce que je
faisais quelque chose avant pis j'aurais
fait quelque chose la place le jpy
pompon ça récemment d'autres pas été
dans le domaine public comme on n'a pas
de pièce maintenant que ces choses là
mais j'aurais été heureux de faire autre
chose aussi fait que c'est pas
d'amertume mais en même temps je suis de
l'avis que tu peux pas vraiment
regretter quoi que ce soit maintenant je
pourrais pas être ailleurs qu'ici les
gens à peu près avoir fait autre chose
que ce que j'ai fait le fait je me dis
qu'il fallait que je fasse oui j'ai
chine dans le processus de de pauvreté
c'est aussi un autre bain en jeu à
débloquer puis d'homme tout est bon là
dedans de vivre en mode solution ouais
règles aux as
ça sert à rien questionné
sur sa cheville et puis wever c'est
comme quand ça arrive où tu peux faire
le le débrief de dire à qui le succès
passé pourquoi qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
que ça arrive plus mais lloris tu peux
jamais te demander qu'est-ce que je peux
faire pour que ça arrive pas
arriver effet club peut dire qu'est ce
que ça aurait pu mais là ce moment
c'est vrai c'est vraiment rare en fait
ça arrive pas qu était que ruminer le
passé
pensez à faire déjà
je n'ai jamais fait ça je pense puis la
projection non plus j'en fais vraiment
pas tant que petit à petit la production
ça peut être vraiment avant les deux
comme projeté ensuite album ça peut être
aussi
s'imaginer
un gazon plus vert ailleurs qu'ivanov
créé des attentes du crédit datant puis
penser que tout va être beau quand ce
devrait être bon quand vous arrivez le
puisque tu vas être bien qu'en ce ça
c'est un autre affaire c'est un piège
aussi à ganges va être lola qu'un joueur
fait sur leur voiture mais le sait le
bonheur se pose parce qu'on
essaie de la femme à la baisse il se
trouvait aujourd'hui c'est d'être
heureux après ça c'est une bonne journée
ta rencontre
puis d'essayer car chaque journée nous
tu te rends compte que tu es bon tu
puisses pas mal ce qui se rapproche le
plus proche de benoît maintenant face
ici à chaque jour du christ et dans le
fond ce que ce que je dis ce que je vis
un moment mais si j'ai le discours que
l'étape 2 de l'avoir ruminer d'avoir
regretter et puis d'être triste par
rapport à ça est vraiment derrière moi
je suis pas heureux en ce moment
vraiment beaucoup même pis c'est juste
et des fois on est moins fiable des six
décisions qu'on peut avoir pris
60 répartie mais jusqu'à parfois
l'exercice comme j'ai rencontré itélé
ligue avec qui j'ai fait aux des gens se
parlent presque tous les jours encore
c'est un fait ça c'est si précieux parce
que même si on est tellement différent
au moins on ne sait pas comment là qu'on
peut se comprendre qui fait du bien
donné des nouvelles juste parce que
j'imagine sans même chose
puis l espèce de chemin que j'ai pu
faire dans ma tête face à ça si cette
crise à mons était sur mon point
tournant pour 4 chez que j'avais besoin
de validation qu'un besoin et aux
scolaires seraient peut-être encore dans
même loupé aujourd'hui une tente est
très présente et est heureux mais
territoire et à déconstruire ce qui est
à reconstruire j'aurai toute la pression
c'est assez d'être heureux p'tit
quinquin carottes lol c'est épuisant
petit arrêt peut-être jeu mais ça a été
positif dans ma rente en serait
définitivement ailleurs c'est impossible
de savoir quelle guitare et mettons sur
astronautes
c'est moi j'ai d'ailleurs pris ma place
qu'à la maison il pouvait plus bouger
mais admettez aujourd'hui mettant en
blanc depuis je souhaite et et une vie
qui est fictif de cheminée puis été
rendu à une place qui était dit qu'ils
étaient peut-être bientôt pas d'accord
ma femme était peut-être mieux car tant
pis urbain jeu content d'avoir rencontré
ma blonde dans ce contexte là parce que
j'ai l'impression que ça m'avait
rencontré après trois ans quatre ans
sans repos clip en tout cas pas du tout
parce que
les son bord deux tons bas de son bord
modifier ses claques ça a cliqué elle a
redit le champ ceni les partis et c'est
beau la loire placebo le sourire le
vendeur de charles de gaulle ça ça leur
ego si beaucoup qui ce j'en suis
reconnaissant parce que j'aurais
l'impression d'avoir monté un christ
titre
quand on a l'impression que je rencontre
quelqu'un qui soit un bon timing quand
même plaque comme feeling cloche content
parce que je pense je rencontrais dans
un bon timing parce que c'était travail
mental là avait été fait avant que
j'aurai encore puis soucier cool pour
ceux
exactitude finale
et peut-être les gens qui veut attirer
outils que tomassi ne seraient pas que
kingdom et ont su que ça a cliqué
serment pour les bonnes raisons pour la
personne qui était vraiment merci ce qui
ne serait pas aussi ce qui fait que ça
mouraient dans l'oeuf les cgp a eu
beaucoup de blanc quand je pense thing
ça marchait juste pas parce que
j'ai j'attirais ce que je voulais pas
avoir je pense
je tombais juste là dedans parce que bon
je suis easy going au lit jusqu'à key
mais ça m'a jamais servi non jamais
jamais jamais vainqueur c'est comme si
dit parlement que ça a été le
le début de ce processus le de
déconstruction et reconstruction que je
compte en avoir vécu ça à 20
35 40 45 56 jeu comptant la voix vie que
ça quand j'ai mis ko dès la 27 e content
d'avoir vécu alors je crois que c'est
j'avais
pointé ses avants de 38 roland une
traque sans
arriver à 40 ans avec leurs deux enfants
puis pas du tout dans le fond l'avis que
si vous voulez puis se rend compte que
tout ce que tu fais ici est imprudent -
dans le fait que dans le paraître mais
qui sait jamais été surpris le rallye et
le ska m2 - raser avant ça arrive est-ce
que vous pensez que
les veuves à réfléchir à vos tricks et
ce comme une idée qui m'est apparu à ce
que ce soit de mal formulée est-ce que
vous pensez que en tant que société on a
trop tendance à
suivre sur une traque sans
la questionner
puis le ca parait vraiment baiser comme
comme question mais je vais prendre
l'exemple aux dés qu'on avait maintenant
moi qui étais vraiment moi aussi en ce
qui me concerne au moins indirecte que
fait que après ça m est arrivé d d d
affaires qui m'ont fait remettre en
question plein de trucs le dernièrement
mais termine en fait mort fait remettre
en question plein de trucs qui à chaque
fois j'en sors grandi
puis je me demande si pour le reste de
ma vie je devrais pas essayer de
chercher
des affaires qui vont
pomme déconstruire pour me reconstruire
mais qui vont me meurs faire remettre en
question - l'ouest que j'en suis dans ma
vie mais on le trouve un peu trop
souvent trop souvent typo3 que la même
avec la même intensité mais de partir
parce qu'on a amené ce facile de
convoquer le
travail at-elle place puis puis famille
décimée d'années de forte de tout le
temps faire un genre de look et check up
sur ma ville en ce moment dit qu'est ce
que je peux faire pour briser cette ça
essayez de voir qu'est ce qui est si bon
qu'est ce qui est négatif d'un ouest que
j'en suis maintenant décideurs construit
sur ce
jeu pas vraiment une question de
réflexion occurrence important de faire
des check up je pense que lorsque c'est
dangereux d'en faire c'est de se dire
pour que je me fasse un check up faut
que je vive quelque chose de fracassant
faut que j'aie quelque chose qu'ils vont
me branler je pense que moyen de se
faire des check up 106 ch et qui trop
méchante à chercher trop quand même ceux
chez qui foutent ramener mathon farah
qui checke
[Musique]
année sabbatique de ma job je m'en veux
sac à dos aussi en asie à prendre cinq
ans le ti ceux chez qui sans se briser
loi et c'est ça le vent de faire et je
m'en veux mettre dans une position
vraiment inconfortable pour ya un gars
que je connais
un ami un ami en amis interposés qui
vote qui quittent qu'il est en voie de
devenir un de mes bons amis on salue on
se moquait de moi
lamy et lui est parti et partir en
europe seule il y avait une bonne job
ici les à 250 milles et des courtiers
immobiliers partie jusque sur une go en
europe le tout vendu ici puis est parti
puis connaissais personne n'y avait pas
de plan rien qui lui son objectif était
de ceux qui n'ont lâché trop confortable
le faut que je sorte d'ici là il ya
quelque chose à faire je sais pas quoi
mais il doit faire qu'il faut que je
chante je sais puis il y est revenu
dernièrement puis j'ai demandé de ce
qu'est ce que tu as appris qu est-ce qui
a changé et puis lui dit que la chose
majeur qui a pris pendant ce triple si
c'était justement ça joue un petit peu
l'idée de l'opinion des autres lui il
était tout le temps mal à l'aise en
rentrant dans des dents les événements
social vous qui connaissez personne
plaît essayez de comprendre pourquoi
qu'est ce qui arrive pl chaque sort il
se mettait dans ses positions le y aller
parce qu'il connaissait personne là bas
et qui d'un an des soirées y avait en
déballant déplace aussi connaissait
personne puis essayer de déconstruire le
qu'est ce qui fait que je suis pas bien
ch'ti quand j'arrive dans une place
parce que je n'ai personne au contraire
je vais être excité de rencontrer une
des nouvelles des nouvelles personnes
affaires nouvelles collections mais je
peux bien oublié commencé à réaliser que
c'était parce que
ils projetaient ce que les gens ce
qu'ils pensaient que les gens pensaient
de lui mais c'était une projection ce
n'est pas ce que les gens pensaient de
lui c'était ce que lui pensait que les
gens pensaient de lui fait que commencer
à comprendre ce plan comprenant 6 et
commencer à déconstruire le truc puis
tranquillement il a commencé à entendre
des places en étant
excité de faire de nouvelles rencontres
de voir des nouvelles personnes doivent
créer d'une nouvelle connexion jusqu'au
moment où est ce que là il y avait plus
aucun malaise dans des salles remplies
d'inconnu mais au contraire c'est de
l'excitation puis du désir de rencontre
vu que ça y est revenu dernièrement
pluie rendant dans son condo et y
reprend pas sa vie parce que prend le
maillot faire autre chose que la job
qu'ils faisaient mais il revient avec ce
candidat qui maintenant cette espèce
d'insécurité log j'avais dans des
contexte social je ne lis plus parce que
bahia valeurs il y avait leur changer si
j'avais eu l'air d'être live changing
comme comme réalisation rigueur là il ya
32 33 pitié si comme tu apprends sont
maintenant mais là maintenant il l'a
dans son sac il a avec lui sur le oui
enfin je me demande si ces affaires leur
faux pas comme ce challenge est moins
sortir des fois il a fort qui nous
arrive qu'ils ne cale en ce sens que
nous on prenne la décision de ce
challenge et mais des fois audun rodem
c'était un peu ça finalement quand
j'étais là où des vouloir c'était
jusqu'à maquillage arrive à un coin
fraude dans ma vie où est ce que je
finis mes études ma carrière de nageur
est terminée qu'est ce que je fais
brisons le batteur faisons quelque chose
de
complètement s'en est suivi des années
d'offres puis mais s'en est suivie la
place où ce que je suis maintenant où
est ce que je me considère comme un jeu
qu'on sort j'ai grandi même dans ces
années là on est bien dans ce sens et
c'est un privilège de vivre des
expériences passées chez qu'un point oui
c'est un gros des gens je pense qu'ils
sont nécessairement je veux faire douter
mais comme ton ami et qui parle d'un en
europe puis qui parle longtemps il a
beaucoup qui aimerait ça se permette de
ce challenge et puis ça je pense que
c'est un privilège de pouvoir se le
permettre mais je pense que on peut ce
challenge et dans les choses super
simple ozil je pense j'ai l'impression à
ce que je vais faire le tour du monde
c'est clair et
on a parlé d'un sol en parler l'autre
jour un super carte avec mathieu
blanchard le temps court ticket
c'est sûr que le le confort khatib
ban dans une situation sais pas ce qui
va être moteur des communaux de
changement puis de 6 comme tout quand il
faisait le 240 show là un petit
grenouille je n'aimais pas au top ten à
tes pantoufles c'était facile à chaque
soir le monde s'est levé sur le cruise
control à d'autres choses puissent être
amendées
un bon salaire tu fais tes pas augmenté
mais genre
tu étais justement comportement
situation le puits a mené si comme ça
prend on manie du témis si toi même
imposé l'espèce de difficulté
supplémentaire de qom ok j'arrête parce
que je pensais que je m'attaque ceux de
mettre ce défilé l'été prochain de
mettre en mode solution et des nouvelles
affaires vous le trouvez tous leurs facs
et ça ça pourrait être
m t'as pas les affaires peuvent qui
t'arrive tu rentres tu as pas d objectif
qui tenait sa proie et changements
d'habitudes bessenay ça va pas des
affaires mais genre qui peut juste
continue creuser ou prendre un esti de
risque votre facture est obligé d com -
trouvé trouvé désoriente enfin que enfin
coin mais c'est correct une fois d'être
confortable dans ses affaires quand tu
as l'impression que tu étais en bonne
place mais qu'at t confortement des
affaires plutôt pas l'impression d'être
bonne place pendant la bombe est capital
pour dire let's go des dab et l'histoire
peut se traduire par huit des trucs
parce que c'est j'ai utilisé une trace
super kitsch pour signifier le fait que
je voulais l'or chez les bars justement
pis je disais à ce moment là
ces genres
c'est pas important des pentes of que je
vais faire les grandes randonnées
puis à ce moment là je m'en rendais
compte parce que
des fois je faisais des rentrées
universitaires y avait 800 personnes
puis le show pas fonctionné au but puis
on sait que ça ait
de tels fonds
supposent
une
petite chance puis sylvie pu faire qui
était clairement pas bonne place ouais
c'est ça moi c'est moi tu mets ton ce
feeling leur faisant un peu la même
affaire que toi fond des choses je l'aï
vu débuter première année c'est comme
qui sema l'aplomb construite quoi plus
le monde triple sait comment donner un
bon show même en essais comme rapidement
tu arrives à hauteur de plafond que tu
peux aller en faisant soit plus tu le
fais pas dans la boue depuis amman et
c'est comme le jour la barbotte
lieberman sidiki non ça peut pas être se
suffit de brune consécutive le pilat vis
à vis de 2 go de 23 ans 25
mai sais pas la prudence vider quelqu'un
45 ans qui entame hippiques été amenés
c'est comme
moins évident pire c'est que ça fait son
temps clairement clairement tous à ne
pas manquer non plus ce que je peux
comprendre non c'est ce témoin dans le
fond là
un peu comme toi moi la pandémie star
vit un moment où est ce que ça faisait
longtemps que j'ai ayez de me distancer
tranquillement mais jamais de capable de
couper le cordon complètement passer le
cordon financière
c'est en avion de tiken jah l'urgence ce
qui payais mes affaires c'était comme
acquis mais il est finalement de fil en
aiguille fini par rester là dedans pire
est pas avoir le temps de faire ce que
ses facultés à moitié il est hyper par
les mises en fait comme toujours les
mêmes bombes c'est fini le hir le pôle
choix ces deux métaux en mode solution
si on retrouve trouve de quoi de nouveau
trouvé rien vendu assez calmes et
gentils moins ça fait chier ça faisait
deux fois mais pour choix at il un bon
choix
puis le team étant têtus beaucoup
réinventer te fait des jobines ici et là
d'être essayé d affaires n en ce moment
non mais j'ai juste comme
aller plus maligne dans ce que je
faisais à temps partiel
les originaux et travailler sur des
projets vraiment des créations - les
projets qui me font vraiment tripé à
paris a pris le temps mais c'est
vraiment bon à ce que tu fais avec a
réussi c'est vraiment cool à ses fins
non c'est ce que tu avais aussi le thème
aussi le studio en parallèle ses
podcasts l'ifex n'est pas comme des pubs
nécessairement plus de rentrées de
moniteurs 06 - seppi 6 ap sipa selon lui
commencer
éventuellement à verser des montants
pour ce qu'on fait ici fakty le
maintenant
la ville et la vie bras prend pas
vraiment son cours métier comme
j'ai eu les opportunités d comme que je
rends grâce est très loin puis comme vu
que j'avais eu le temps puis
l'opportunité de comme
m'installer plus comme il faut dans les
enfants que je vais vraiment faire
bouger comme l'est celle très basse et
ses points ça va être ça - qui fait que
dans un sens justement cet obstacle de
difficultés le qui est la pandémie fait
en sorte que je me suis même aux
solutions piqué jeu mais je me servirai
bord pis pour le mieux dans le fond tu
il faut le sang pour sang s'écoule sopi
tout commence à travailler c'était
projet leurs musiques originales font
plus sérieusement pendant la pandémie
mais tu me parlais au début que tu as
très orienté quand les salles de
spectacle ont fermé mais traiter plus
besoin de couper famous jg ici toutes
sortes de choses quand j'ai vu mathieu
l'année passée
bon il couvre feu plustek en manquait
peut-être que je vais pouvoir commencer
à faire des shows plus les rumeurs
disaient que ça allait le couvre-feu
quelques heures puis c'est à ce moment
là ça fait longtemps que j'avais sorti
du top original aussi fait que si je
voulais faire des shows mais bon là je
recommence à faire du corps parce que
j'avais comme peu de nouveaux matériels
nécessairement présenté à des booker
pour qu'ils me bloquer pour des
premières parties et la fecq jacques un
bon ben ok ben il est chaud je dois
faire ça va tout cet été en cover puis à
ce moment là je sais comment je suis
tanné d'être chez moi puis de recevoir
comme un tyran la pcr à ce moment là
c'est une belle béquilles mais
je voulais pas me puis je voulais pu
m'appuyer là dessus parce que je me
sentais pas utile je me sens leur
valorisons
j'ai l'impression que si je restais chez
nous encore trop longtemps ça allait
venir plus qu'autre chose fait qu'elle
était passée j'ai posé des piscines ok
oui j'ai fait quelques mois cet été puis
j'ai redécouvert les joies de se lever
tôt le matin pisté kulti je passais mes
journées dehors il faisait beau puis en
steaks ou lensois puis elle était
choisie les chaudes corrupteurs cet
automne
g j'ai commencé à faire des stocks a
exactement mon poste s'était in his
moniteur à l'initiation musicale
j'allais dans les garderies en milieu
familial cp1 ok je faisais des activités
musicales pour les 0 à 5 ans tous ces
appareils c'était quand même cool soins
ça c'était vraiment cool puis je me suis
rendu compte à ce moment là que c'est
c'est valorisant investi des enfants car
si tu veux un petit gars de trois ans il
dit pas un mot mais double on a noté
quant à qui ça c'est cool petit en
europe c'est bye monsieur musique puis
c'est les petits colliers ses cuisses
avant de partir j'étais convoqué wawa
qu'il n'ya pas juste les chaudes en voir
qu'ils peuvent me faire du bien
finalement un pin's semaine j'ai été
j'ai écrit des contes pour enfants c'est
vraiment à la mode et puis des fois des
fois je croise des jeunes maintenant
envie de salon du lait vous avez des
salons d'éducation de la faim même pays
que je n'y connaissais mettons à mener
je me rappelle il y avait imposture
donne des personnages avaient créé qui
s'appelait maquis qui est un singe et
ingénieurs puis
les enfants passent à côté de ces gamins
ces maquis puis connaissait le
personnage il était content plus c'est
gratifiant maison d'avoir deux chars ont
eu un impact et mettront dans la vie nos
enfants dans son apprentissage
c'est par pure le contactant site
apprécié sur le sens si tu apprécies pas
tous a aussi fait qu'il ya eu les
piscines il ya eu ça puis le quinqua
noël
je commençais à me rées entouré parce
que bon jeu cet été j'avais
réenregistrer - pixar en mars là le sac
commencé à je m'étais trouvé un bouquin
je commençais à m'entourer puis ça qui
colorie ali prend à partie et ça va
commencer probablement janvier fait
cracher est parfait je veux continuer à
être moniteur à l'initiation musicale
pour les enfants puissent voir faire ça
aussi ça va être parfait je me couchais
qu'un sourire à tous les soirs c'est
certain puis le bon un micro et un micro
puis l espèce de petite rumeur qui
disait que bomba les enfants même s'ils
ont des symptômes ils peuvent y aller
comme impies même chose pour les fait
qu'à ce moment là je t'ai connu un jour
arrêter ça ça n'a pas de bon ça fait que
je me suis mis en mode solution puis
j'ai commencé à travailler comme
assistant de projet dans une compagnie
construction j'ai commencé ça il ya
peut-être trois semaines puis je trouve
ça cool je conçois quand je me lève en
même temps que jean omer c'est cool
c'est dire que tout est respect pour
jean ont maintenant pris nommément les
cadres en trois heures et demie c'est à
quoi les sirops de radio ce matin et le
web mais craint que moi ce que je trouve
fou c'est que les shows de radio sont
même pas commencé qu un titre en forme
sort encore la met hors course qui sont
réveillés haut de gamme comme lors que
je me suis couché pendant tellement
d'années que je me lève ses phoques et a
fait classer s'acheter en mode solution
parce que bon j'ai 30 ans j'ai une
hypothèque à payer j'ai un char payer
puis j'ai des responsabilités
financières c'est qu'avec aussi parce
que bon le j'habite montréal mais j'ai
géré de me racheter autre chose d'avoir
une maison
je sais pas si vous vous avez l'appel
des kids mémo avec l automne on doit
puisque plus en plus le jeu commence à
avoir honte à ça aussi fait que je suis
en mode ok j'ai un objectif qu'est ce
que je peux faire pour me rendre puis en
ce moment mais c'est d'un c'est de faire
des heures dans une compagne
construction puis je me croise les
doigts et on aussi cette semaine que les
salles rouvre à 50% fait qu en espérant
que les premières parties recommencent
aussi fait que
ça ressemble pas mal à ce pur moment de
montbarla comment ça
tu acheté à montréal ou en dehors de
bain si je donne le million oui mais
magazine s'est posé question seriez
probablement qu'à voir les moyens je me
poserai pas question que je me dirais
probablement cui mais c'est quoi je
reste quand on te suit un scénario
t'imagines mettons qu'il faut c'est quoi
on dirait que mais mes racines de la
bastille en ardèche et mes parents mais
je pense tout d'abord ma premier set
mais c'est je suis grand j'ai grandi à
hambourg puis en arabe chez mes parents
c'est un grand terrain ensuite une
clôture d un champ dans des valises des
chevaux puis on dirait que je m'ennuie
mais je veux pas trop m'éloigner de
montréal non plus avec streep en lice
lanaudière quel point la nadière je
pense j'ai repensé à ma blonde vient du
coin aussi fait que je me suis dit tant
qu'à est à 3h de mitt romney gaupillat
famille aussi bien me rapprocher de la
famille à ma blonde aussi mais ouais là
nadia je trouve ça beau je le découvre
beaucoup depuis deux ans puis j'aime
bien ça les la clé les forêts et les
rivières puis c'est pas trop loin
montréal facussé la rue des halles ce
serait une petite maison de bois il ya
un appel la nature mais je me dis leur
symbole ne leur semble que je suis
abonné à des des groupes sur facebook
qui m'envoient des muses parce que dans
ma situation actuelle c'est pour rêver
mais des groupes de marveaux des maisons
de en estrie puis d'un canton de lettres
puis certaines pisé boléro mon pays
c'est des maisons comme abordable
refaite avec une terrain fini puis des
montagnes pour aller courir à dans ta
cour arrière
donne le goût on dirait - morial ça m'a
jamais rien fait john attachement très
fort à québec très très bien je pense
retourner à québec plus calés en estrie
mais il ya comme un appel la nature on
dirait on dirait que je sature et
surtout que je réalise que
90% de ce que je fais je peux le faire
n'importe où c'est ça ouais c'est ça on
est inconsciemment drake montréal fois
et là
on a l'impression qu'ils avaient dans
marianne mais en fait on du monde il ya
une fille une fausse adresse et genre tu
peux tu peux mettre une fausse adresse à
montréal mais d'orienter union des
artistes le même sort d'un film le ton
si tu aurais un rôle qui t'habite
mettons à sherbrooke mais là ils veulent
pas payer le déplacement tout comme on
dit ce matin adresse à montréal que dans
l'union des artistes à morialmé
finalement tu habites semaine je sais
pas où le plus quand on a une semaine de
tournage
parce que ceux ci sont prêts à faire
sauter dans un syndicat mettons ce dépôt
la ville
sera même pas penser peut-être pas juste
de hype à montréal je râle toi c'est sûr
c'est tout l'art et prennent à djabla
maison qu'ils auraient voyagé à ton été
genre à patrice michaud vincent
vallières qui sont ici les deux parcs de
genre ni de sherbrooke le diabète est
d'un coût de maguelone mettons
l'intrépide chacun besoin de venir en
ville ils font une heure et quart de
sharp espace post payés dans le fond
bien se passer sinon ils y ont pu
acheter une maison qu'ils ont pu faire
le plot petit niblock villa belle petit
jeu ils y ont pas nécessairement besoin
d'être cinq jours sur sept à montréal
n'ont plus trop où la nécessité si tu
viens pour un show télé un podcast des
entrevues ou à l'erreur mais le
déplacement vaut la peine
de paris
mais si ça c'est clair mais moi ça
faisait longtemps que j'avais comme
l'appelle décès montréal
mary calmes alors je suis allé sur ces
spéciales comme comme timing parce que
bon je suis propriétaire d'un condo à
québec puis début 2020 je m'étais dit
bon ces logements à montréal fait que je
me suis trouvé un locataire pour mon
condo à québec je te comme d'un
prochains mois je regarderai pas me
trouver de quoi montréal plus à un mois
et demi après il est arrivé la pandémie
fait que j'ai j'ai signé mon bail sans
avoir visité mon appart fait que j'étais
arrivé en juin 2020 à montréal
l'idée que je m'étais fait de montréal
un avenant temps partiels et provisoires
des choses je vais rencontrer du monde
est
[Rires]
perdant c'est un thé la pandémie mais
quand t'es jamais at-elle placé jamais
sorti nantais c'est la fin du genre de
publicité que je vis ici c'est la
pandémie gens je n'ai rien vécu
vécu le même truc tu es tu arrivé à
montréal un but avait mariale peu avant
après pandémie dans le talent avec
rihanna ouais
on était dans le nom de daoud sic après
ceux à penser à moi j'ai déménagé dans
heureusement une telle un colloque
français
greg
l'arrangement
puis après s'être injecté à jean lardin
micro micro climat y est un véhicule
montverdun camp
non c'est un métier moi je suis quand
même bien sûr aussi je tends rosemont
petite patrie avec le spot est cool mais
alors là c'est triste pour toutes les
boutiques fermées
salut c'est moi sa vie 26 ans on le voit
si peu l'été lequel n'a envie
d'argumenter terrasse avec l'espoir
qu'ils aient
[Rires]
non mais je n'ai pas vécu un quart mais
là ça fait deux ans que je suis un
ménage à montréal puis
et pas grand chose qui me retient
vraiment ici qui doit revenir pour des
obligations professionnelles
je vois pas la nécessité mais c'est pour
cela que j'ai un petit 45 minutes de
montréal ça me dérange pas aussi je
regarde regarde centristes quand même
agressivement vraiment
quelque chose de
façon
qatar est malade
mais bien quand quelqu'un je regarde moi
j'aimerais ça me trouver de quoi c'est
parce que moi je t'ai gens réalisent
attache à québec le projet depuis mon
équipe travaille québec bablon la moria
active tout en un peu tiraillé entre ces
deux villes a maintenant fait qu'amener
j'ai comme fait plus j'ai encore le
studio au québec parce que tout ce que
je fais de la musique que j'ai fait et
qu'il a pu je peux plus le faire autant
d'allers retours de deux fois semaine ou
à la main agrisa langues on m'a laissé
dur cinquième
mois c'est le che qui quelque part entre
les deux c'est une espèce d'entre d'eux
qui redonne au meeting donc drôme on est
juste un peu
et et ait à 1h30 de chaque bar mc cela
qui est poésie du roman ni et des bosses
pas tu as commencé sur hbo et rien de
vraiment le métier mais moi j'ai le goût
justement de l'appel la nature comme on
dit le team par un genre de chalets avec
un studio et que le monde vient
d'enregistrer piqué on passe une semaine
le qu'on va prendre des marches dans le
boyau puis continue tu sais ce que
j'imagine en forme à mes origines traits
d'un pelletier grille des salaires 6 ans
porte exact il vous s'acheter une maison
à s'intéresser aux métiers ton pour moi
c'est pas si québec ce trop loin c'est
parce que ceux ci s'est rendue mais
l'échangé problème local a démarré à
wismes et un c'est pas comme ça mais
quand les gens te tente une belle juste
quelque chose
débattez dans nature de fait un spot
pour créer pour être comme dans ta bulle
moins que tu peux recevoir du monde pour
justement faire enregistrer des
tournages sera l'album c'est ce seul
plan mais mène en ce moment le tout ce
qui sort le jeu commencé à envoyer 10
que je te disais tantôt quant à envoyer
des gens avec un kiki quelque chose que
160 risque m'intéresse j'intéressais
juste et puis ils me répondent tout le
temps genre est ok parfait ben oui on a
25 visites dissidents deux jours puis
faute d'importantes offres d'achat
c'est comme qui georges chèque mais
georges je suis prêt mais je pense que
ça ne sert à rien de regarder ce que les
gens regardent des maisons qui sont
listées mettons dans mon budget oui mais
genre au final le monde mon pays j'aurai
50 % plus cher parce que à ce que fais
tu sais c'est rohff c'est le sport
c'est andres est partout
fac
on vieillit les explications de québec
je reviens québec le 1er juillet le gpo
financer je reviens le savent sans aucun
doute un appartement pour pour commencer
mais ça va venir ici pour les porter et
podcasts et puis le ce que je fais c'est
qu'à chaque deux semaines je retourne à
québec un aller retour pour aller voir
mon monde puis j'habite dans une ville
que j'aime pas tant que ça va je dois
faire l'inversé j'aurais pu enlever le
cas gm je ferai des retours pour un job
mais mais maintenant je me suis trouvé
loin cette année puis avec la pandémie
de ces mots ma soeur de kate enfants mes
neveux nièces et puis ma famille mes
parents le sont les parrains ils
rajeunissent pas non plus les hôtes ont
vieilli mais tout le monde y est en même
temps ça fait deux ans je trouve loin
mais quand je revois mon monde je trouve
ça fait longtemps que j'ai vu je trouve
que j'ai été bon mais je paye mes
parents une fois par semaine ces puits
le jeu ne fait plus depuis nancy
- moi aussi je trouve ça quand même plat
devant mais par un ou deux mois plus
qu'une fois par semaine comment un temps
que j'étais à québec aussi c'est ça
ouais ouais vraiment vous si j'avais
peur pour ma blonde se seraient déjà
aidé sud de montréal tableau est du
québec
[Musique]
mais c'est d'abord quelqu'un au jour le
jour mais qui donne envie de rester
alité xac rester mais qui était juste
quelqu'un avec toi aussi c'est plutôt
que d être tout seul en attendant à moi
tout seul c'est moi je suis solo dans
l'ombre que c'est qu'à chaque jour je me
réveille je me dis c'est là soit on
travaille quand même ou studios qui ont
fait affaire mais à chaque jour ne
diffuse aucune raison d'être si m rien
ne dit rien ici le dit rien je pourrais
te prendre s'il est maintenant des
boîtes demain matin puis ma vie serait
pareil le fait que fait que non c'est ça
qu'est ce qu'on encaisse compte chèques
qu'est ce qu'il en est pour toi c'est le
temps de
jeu bien sortir une tonne
ben y'a pas plus tard que je sais pas
quand est le podcast au passé mais j'ai
sorti une tonne à fin janvier je mets
tout échec pauvres et l'anglais ça ça
c'est drôle comment c'est arrivé tu
connais un peu sam bono tu connais
la théâtralité de l'oeuvre de ce golf
c'est que ça met pas mal tout ça en fait
mes photos puis un simple y montrait
beaucoup caméra antique sur film puis
quand est venu le temps de faire des
tests photo pour la tonne qui s'en
venait il y avait une pénurie de photos
en coule de films en couleur partout en
programmant trouver comment on fait des
tests noir et blanc puis le kompa c'est
quand même beaucoup de jours à faire des
tests parce que bon on cherchait des
films couleurs au départ presse à faire
des tests subis
manning zappi à parle de quotas tonnes
qui étaient passés avec elle et
éventuellement faire les clips tout avec
le gie parle de ça les jours abandonné
ses je vais j'avais l'impression que
je me faisais abandonne ainsi qu'un cash
pointé la pandémie du doigt des bulls
à la vie voilà c'est un petit peu ça
puis en écrivant atone je me suis rendu
compte que c'était à moi d'apprendre
abandonné plein de trucs au final
puisque c'était seul le cheminement
faire puis le samedi
sa grande sagesse m'a dit tu
l'impression à l'idée fois que les vices
comme joue aux échecs
plongée dit qu'est ce tu as their 10h
pas que chaque petit move que tu peux
faire autant que ça peut te servir
autant que ça peut tenir que tu sais
jamais vraiment ça va être servi au
savon noir piqué moment donné ça se peut
que tu ailles un fou qui arrive blind
side ça peut arriver plus d'être fou
bref le géant les foules temps 45 en
arrière puis ça a été aussi simple que
ça pue mais dimanche je connais une
place un parc que ça joue aux échecs
constamment ses djs masters le sont
complètement débile puis monde et rien
que j'avais aux échecs
ça doit être quand j'étais qu'il n'avait
jamais jamais poursuivi c'est vrai
pendant avec l'ubs vous avez ouvert mais
j'avais j'avais quel bonhomme faisait
quoi comme trajectoire c'était pas mal
ça fait que je trouvais que ça faisait
beaucoup avec le clip de jeux salle et
en toute humilité me faire donner des
leçons des chèques par du monde qui ont
de l'expérience
puis ça a été ça la résultante du
pourquoi je tallinn faire fondre aux
échecs
puis ligoté tellement intéressant il y
avait un monsieur qui était leur d'avoir
70 ans dans ce coin-là puis vous me
racontez que dans sa jeune vingtaine y
allait souvent joué à des tournois en
europe qui avait
pris par les deux je me rappelle pas de
nom mais d'un joueur russe qu'elle lit
c'était
sa soeur avait
indiqué qu' que jouer contre
l'ordinateur le ch'ti comme le premier
ordinateur deep blue que ça vienne
blouin des blues et comme genre
intéressante ici que je vaux échec
battus au québec celui d'eric un sport
qui était un matelas en mousse 23 kg en
tout cas il me contait s'abstenant
intéressant là le contact que la
rencontre humaine depuis puis non je
suis content d'être là chanson
a bien reçu en radio puis ça s'annonce
bien pour la suite tandis que sam un
mini spotlight peut-être sur le pays
sort le 4 mars fait chemin existait
d'autres ça je me croisaient les doigts
aussi que les choses commencent bientôt
on va croiser les doigts les kings
j'aimerais ça une robe dénommé je peux
pas tant que c'est pas confirmé
confirmer mais je viens d'en parler sur
ses actifs situés en parler le monde qui
nous écoutent qui veulent te suivront -
ils vont pour aller voir son site ou sur
le vix couture point ca instagram
facebook chut toc toc toc toc et
j'essaie et hector sa prothèse moi je
sais comme hakim on indique taxer les
jeunes morts jetait canon ça c'est de
l'humour
damanaki
j'ai essayé puis j'ai un compte mais
j'ai jugé plus l'application fait que
mais non mcnabb choses les plus
folles et
salut
merci à l'immense avatar merci
énormément légaux pauvret j'apprécie
beaucoup qui avec mes invités je t'ai
bien content
du contenu excellent tu as tout un
pataquès combien
oui
si vous voulez plus de contenu excellent
comme ce que vous venez d'entendre aller
sur le patriote le pitch vous abonner
pour trop de l'or parmi six autres au
delà ouais trois pièces par morlaàs par
mois et vous avez les podcasts en
avançant qu'ils appuient premier de
votre groupe d'amis à recruter les
podcasts qu'ils allaient avoir pouvoir
avoir une avance quand vous allez tuer
le la dynamique entre les amis de tout
le temps avec une avance sur les jobs en
avance les gens autour de toi mais avec
pétillante une avance sur l'humanité
complète en plus en plus parce que laure
le podcast fini voulu nous en dire
davantage on fait des encore moins de
filtres à préchac podcast avec le on
vient de finir de tourner le podcast on
va en jaser on va te filer nicole non
nicoli pleut maintenant comme un fils
travaille la place
elle a détaillé le mets en jason par la
conversion convient d'avoir mais ceux ci
vous avoir accès
mais heureusement pour nous
malheureusement pour vous c'est exclusif
sur pékin il faut s'abonner abonnez vous